you mentioned you appeared on the pbd
podcast with Patrick bad David
um the debate was pretty intense
I wasn't I I should say I personally
enjoyed it I thought uh actually you did
well and I thought Patrick did well it
was a good conversation I think there's
a little bit of tension yeah and I I
thought that Patrick actually so I
disagreed with the internet I thought
Patrick just took on a kind of Devil's
Advocate like he was he was purposely
being stubborn to bring out the best in
you but the internet thought that he's
being stubborn not being open to your
ideas I thought the tension between
ideas
um I think a lot of the tension had to
do probably with uh Donald Trump and
Trump supporters that certainly could be
the case and people wrote to me after
people wrote To Me the full gamut of
everything you can imagine from this was
your best thing you've ever done in
public to you got humiliated and your
mother should have aborted you okay so
every and everything in between so you
know take your pick but
um
the most interesting feedback I got was
from people who asked me after was it
incredibly tense and awkward and because
it seemed so combative and I think
for I'm so used to those types of
tensions in the discussions that I have
that it's very comfortable to me it's
not like afterwards it's it's there's a
grudge or it's tense or whatever the
case may be I'm very comfortable just I
I disagree with people and that's it so
I did not find anything that happened
inappropriate I disagreed with a lot of
the things he said certainly